well now i would like to present our
next speaker
so dr luis vasquez quinones is an
assistant professor of biology and
molecular cell biology at anna g mendez
university
he is also the co-director of the
bioinformatics resource corp
program from pr inbri and leads the
orientation portion of puerto rico's
community of practice in bioinformatics
dr vazquez quinones was first exposed to
bioinformatics when he was an
undergraduate student through an
introductory computer science course
during the course he learned some
programming skills but it wasn't until
he was re-exposed to bioinformatics
through a graduate course that he became
interested in data analysis
later in his career dr vasquez quinones
was able to integrate aspects of
bioinformatics into academic courses and
research so that his students could be
exposed to bioinformatics similarly to
how he was
dr vasquez quinones is also involved in
teaching outreach programs and
encourages students to reach out to
experts to help them learn
apart from his teaching and research
responsibilities
vasquez quinones is also the co-director
of the prn bioinformatics research
cohort and an active member of the
puerto rico community of practice and
bioinformatics
the goal of this community practice and
bioinformatics is to reconnect the
puerto rico institutions together to
create a community of active and open
research with a focus on data science
and bioinformatics
so with that please join me in welcoming
dr luis vasquez quinones
hello everyone
hello welcome can you see my
screen
yes we can
okay hello everyone today i am going to
talk to you about
the bioinformatics training
opportunities that puerto rico indre is
offering on during this grand cycle 2021
2025. the title for my presentation
bioinformatics training opportunities to
the community of practice model
the general outline for my presentation
is
where is puerto rico ingram located on
the world map what is a community of
practice
uh the stages for a community of
practice what we have been doing for the
implementation of the community of
practice with an update
uh by informatics community of
practicing training opportunities
uh and other training opportunities to
the puerto rico
network
benefits of the bioinformatics community
of practice acknowledgements and answer
questions
for those of you that do not know puerto
rico is located in the caribbean and
puerto rico imbre belongs to the
southeast region of the ingres program
community of practice is a
knowledge-based social structure that
enables groups of people
to share a passion in our case
bioinformatics for a domain to interact
regularly and deepen their knowledge and
expertise in that domain
a community of practice is comprised of
three key elements the domain that is a
common interest in a field or area of
knowledge consists of key problems
experience experienced by members in our
case the domain is bioinformatics with
the goal of increasing bioinformatics
and computational skills among our
members
um the second element is the community
that should be our voluntary members
that share the interest in the domain
and actively participate in designing
activities and dialogues for the
fundamental goal of increasing knowledge
and solving problems through interaction
so in our case the community will be the
scientists around puerto rico
researchers on teaching faculty students
undergrads and graduate students as well
the their element is the practice that
are a collection of methods techniques
tools information stories resources etc
that members use together to advance the
goals of the community of practice
in our case our practice will be for
research and education
in this slide you can see that a
community of practice has five stages
uh potential coalescing maturing
stewardship and transformation
during the potential state faculty for
from predominantly undergraduate
institution also known as puis in our
case
have a high academic workload among
other responsibilities that represents a
barrier to keeping up with changes in
the field of bioinformatics
in addition these institutions also lack
computational capabilities
when the coalescing stage on this model
the community of practice model will
bring together a community of scientists
and trainees from around the island to
facilitate collaboration at the research
and educational level
that will increase the number of
scientists using bioinformatics and to
prepare the next generation of
scientists
the third stage is maturing
in which activities directed to increase
bioinformatics and computational skills
in non-bioinformatic scientists will be
designed and developed in collaboration
with pr imbre bioinformatics resource
core also known as buick to offer
community workshops interventioning
courses or laboratories as requests of
the institutions
the fourth stage stewardship on this
community of practice level
is rich when a satisfactory biodramatic
proficiency has been reached among the
members on the fifth stage that is
transformation
this is the ultimate stage of the
community of practice when the
scientific community is integrated and
willing to collaborate beyond the world
of each institution at the research and
educational level
currently we are at stage number two and
three coalescing because we are bringing
together
every scientist around the island with
interest in this um initiative
and mastering because we already uh
started our development we already
developed uh the initial workshops that
is in language
and we are um designing more
more workshops to be offered
um is the purpose of puerto rico invade
to increase the interaction between
researchers teaching faculty and
students around the island
uh
the community will play uh an essential
role to foster these instructions to
increase the bioinformatics skills
among our members
so starting with the training
opportunities uh
the training and education support
support led by me
uh design the lioness workshop in which
the members of the bioinformatics
community of practice will have access
to the computational resources offered
by the vocaron cluster of the
high-performance computing facility at
the university of puerto rico
this uh the high compartment high
performance computing facility is laid
by dr umberto ortiz sosaga at the
university of puerto rico and he is
supporting us
and his team by
providing the accounts for our members
the operating system of the vocaron is
linus and the participants will be
learning the most common
commands to be ready for future
bioinformatic worship
in this
figure you can see that we have already
identified
a total of 30 institutions around the
island
in the lower left corner of the slide
you can see the legend
uh and the colors of the stars uh
reflects the the progress that we
already achieved with each institution
uh the number next to some of the stars
uh indicates how many of the three
aligners workshop have already been
received
uh a total of 20 out of the thirty
institutions have already accepted the
invitation
have already identified a leader for the
community of practice the local
community of practice
have already coordinated or are in the
process of coordinating uh the initial
meeting
to talk about the initiatives uh or
already received the the orientation i
started coordinating the workshop or
already received them
um
currently we are
still paying efforts by contacting the
the third of the institution that
haven't responded yet
in this slide you can see pictures of
the
trainings that have been going on around
the island uh in a virtual or in person
uh fashion
uh i have been visiting uh
the communities around the island and
this one is in the north part of the
island in the north park
center
uh this other one is in the northeast
part of the island
this one is in in the north and this one
is in the south
uh we have been providing three lineus
pressure with enough time of interaction
with the participants to answer their
specific questions
but as well to explore their
the community interests so once when
they have completed the three uh part of
the workshops uh follow-up meetings are
scheduled uh to explore
new workshops based on their interests
or coordinated additional lines workshop
for additional faculty and students
in this slide you can see l
in this picture you can see a typical
slide to explain a command in an easy
step-by-step a way in which uh uh this
increase the execution of the
participants and all participants
receive this detail of presentations
by a onedrive link
so those are presentations serves as
reference for future
uh and the near future
additional workshops
continuing with
the training opportunities the next one
will be for next generation sequencing
workshop
the oxford nano forming ion will be used
as a portable sequencing device to train
our members in sample sequencing data
processing and assembly
the objective is to include new
laboratory experiences in biology
curricula to impact our students around
the island but also to include
these approaches and for research
the lioness knowledge is important for
this kind of question
the next uh training opportunity uh that
we have then uh identified is relational
databases database constitutes an ideal
framework for representing and
analyzing large datasets in biology
a structured query language is one of
the most common tools used in the field
of data science that you have heard a
lot during this
symposium
relational databases allow users to
formulate and answer questions about the
data our participants will learn an
efficient way
to manipulate the land datasets
currently nowadays having our skills are
very important for biologists
so in that sense we are going to be
offering our workshop in which our
members will
have the opportunity to learn art to
analyze their data and generate thoughts
r is used widely in several disciplines
it's free which allows scientists to
analyze their data without expanding in
commercial programs in addition
um
uh r has a lot of bioinformatics free
tools that are available to analyze data
for current uh biological and emerging
uh biological essays
another opportunity comes from the
metagenomic support led by dr philippe
pagody vitorino to the puerto rico in
the network this support will train
researchers of pilot projects that
include a metagenomic component such as
microbiome studies
the support will assist in the
implementation of projects data
production data analysis and manuscript
publication
in addition the support will be offering
a metagenomics workshop to the members
of the community of practice later on
the semester or during the summer
another good opportunity for our members
will be
comes
and comes from the professional
certificate in data sign
led by professor carlos ortiz dr abiel
roche lima dr estoni dallus santana
this uh data science certificate is
comprised of four courses introduction
to data science
main applications in data science data
science application with machine
learning and data science final project
the role of the community of practice
will be to promote this certificate
among our members so they can benefit
from this opportunity
uh in this slide you can see a picture
of the most recent participants that
have already completed the certificate
certification
and currently uh more than one hundred
like 68 participants have completed the
certification from people around the
island of puerto rico
uh i think that three two or three
person from um el salvador
and two from the main usa
another opportunity uh that is available
for our members comes from this a
computational biologist court labor
professor anatoly charney
he collaborates with puerto rico in
researchers students and structural
associates
on research projects relevant to
bioinformatics research
currently he is developing a java
desktop application called assistant of
metabolized selection
for gas chromatography mass spectrometry
research
we will be inviting professor anatoly
cherny so he can provide um training
opportunities for the members of our
community so he will become an
instructor as well as doctor
perichi guerrada would be invited to
become an instructor he is leading the
support in a statistic and he provides
statistical services
to predominantly
undergraduate institution researchers
during the production of scholarly work
and to those preparing proposal
this course works in collaboration with
the
computational biologists of course
to support our researchers
and in this slide i am summarizing the
benefits of the of belonging to the
bioinformatics community of practice
uh
access to the high performance computing
facility located at the at the high
performance computing facility uh
through the vocational cluster our
members will be able to um request
accounts
and that's account those accounts can be
used for research purposes um education
like in courses or laboratories and for
training purposes
educational materials for courses and
labs will be shared with faculty members
that will incorporate these um
experiences as part of their of part of
their courses or laboratories
and from medicine computational training
scientists around the island and
institutions around the island will
benefit from the faculty development
program
in bioinformatics for their faculty
bioinformatics seminars seminars that
are coordinated
through puerto rico
will be available to our members so they
can um
attend to those as well
uh the directors of puerto rico in
records will give orientation talks to
our members so they can know
the services that they provide here at
the island uh so they can consider those
services when they are writing uh
research proposals uh educational
proposals or both
the last one research and educational
networking
the scientists around the island will
have a system in place in which they can
collaborate um ideas
um efforts
in order for to increase uh
bioinformatics and
with people they can um collaborate
like um collaborate
for
solving issues that other people are
facing
um
nowadays
i would like to acknowledge that this
project is supported by a wide number
p20 gm 103475
from the [ __ ] ms of the nih
thanks to all my colleagues at the pr
inbree
here in puerto rico and thanks to the
organizers of this symposium for
inviting me
inviting me uh to give this presentation
thank you very much dr vasquez quinones
that was a wonderful presentation
we have a few questions for you
uh the first one is how did you get
involved with bioinformatics and pr and
brie
okay uh my
path in bioinformatics i started as an
undergrad when i was exposed to the
programming course
then i got involved as a graduate
student in the first bioinformatics
course
uh taught at my institution
and then i reconnect with uh the people
that taught me bioinformatics at the
peaceful supercomputing center i'm my
past mentor in bioinformatics
and then one day i was at the medical
sciences campus talking to dr jose
rodriguez medina that is the pi
and
we were in the hall and he was asking so
many questions
and it was funny because i
told him my vision
to improve bioinformatics skills around
the island
and i talked about the device domination
device and
few weeks later i was receiving the
device
and then he invited me
to form part of the of the team that was
providing the renewal for puerto rico
and that was that
i started my path uh dealing with
bioinformatics and the nih
brought me the idea of the community of
practice
so we can benefit here in puerto rico
around the island increasing the
bioinformatics
great thank you
uh another question
how many students do you aim to train in
the next year
uh well currently i have been teaching
the bioinformatics course uh since i
arrived here at uh universidad dana
mendes so i have been impacting more
than 100 students
so
i think
that we will be impacting a lot of
students because i am
creating a critical mass but attending
first the professors
that are teaching the courses around the
island
so in the near future i think that
everyone will be
um receiving training in bioinformatics
because my vision is that we no longer
have any students mainly from biology
that exit a program without these kids
so i i have to say a lot of them
that's great to hear
okay i don't think we have any more
questions for you thank you again for
presenting that was a very wonderful
talk